hello and thanks for joining us today
my name is brandon hopkinson i am a
product marketing manager at vizio farm
and i'll be your moderator for today's
lecture today we'll have two speakers
david mason vizio farms technical
specialist trained as a cell biologist
and microbiologist he has spent over a
decade in academia specializing in light
microscopy
and digital image analysis we also have
keith bowers the senior business
development manager at oracle bio
keith has over 25 years of experience in
large pharma
biotech and the contract services sector
today's lecture will be an overview of a
vizio farm oracle bio workflow
where david will demonstrate the tools
available within the vizio farm
platform and how they can be used to
support a range of image analysis
workflows
keith will then discuss how oracle bio
integrates these tools into a
customer-centric
scalable workflow to generate value for
drug discovery
and project development thank you very
much for your time today guys and i'm
excited for the presentation so i'll let
you take it from here
david you'll begin so please start
whenever you're ready
thanks for the introduction in the first
part of today's talk
i'd like to introduce the vizio farm
platform and tools
the vizio farm platform can really be
thought of as an easy to use
toolbox not to solve a single problem
but to solve a range of image analysis
problems
to support not only the research and
work of today
but those of tomorrow as well
the vizio farm toolbox has integrated
into it a core set of tools
these features are easy to use
for building apps in this case apps are
our modular unit
of image analysis processing the deep
learning classifiers
are built right into these tools and
easy to use it's very important to us
that the the outputs
also be customizable again every single
question you ask of your data will
require
different metrics and another pillar
that the vizio farm software is built on
is that there'd be no coding required
and this makes it really easy for users
to come in
and start building apps to solve
problems with very little lead time
you can see from these example images
that we also accept a wide range of
modalities
using the core tools in this case h e
ihc brightfield as well as fluorescence
and some more exotic file types as well
now the core platform features sometimes
need to be extended
and this is where we introduce modules
modules are additional processing units
that can be added onto the core visio
farm tools
to assist in image analysis workflows
i'm going to touch on these in more
detail today but as a quick introduction
the four modules i'd like to introduce
are tissue array
multiplex phenotyping tissue align
and brain mapping during the course of
the the rest of the first half of this
talk
i'll be touching on each one of these
core tools and modules in a little more
detail
let's start with ai deep learning this
is a really important part of the core
platform
features
complex problems require advanced tools
and in this case many researchers or
other users of image analysis software
start to hit walls with traditional
techniques such as
thresholding or shallow learning
techniques
deep learning really allows you to do a
number of different things including
segment tissue without complex stains
detect
subtle and low car contrast structures
and you can see here from the example
i've put on the left
tumor detection is a great example of
these kinds of low contrast structures
you can hopefully make out that there
are areas here that are slightly darker
blue stained of tumor
small areas in the top left and the
right hand side
and these can be positive or negative
for other ihc
stains trying to detect these with
traditional or shallow learning
techniques is non-trivial activity
the other advantage of deep learning is
that we can build robust apps
that work across a range of stains
across a range of tissues
and right across a range of staining
regimes
in this case for instance we can build
apps that work with h e
and ihc but building robust apps
also means being able to cope with
standard variants that we see in
biological samples
that could be induced by the biology
itself by cut
thickness or staining protocols
another point is that when we can
automatically segment tissue and
identify
regions of interest or areas of interest
we can start to replace
laborious manual tasks such as outlining
areas of interest with automation
and once we've automated a process this
means that it's highly scalable
as another introduction to the deep
learning tools it's worth mentioning
that all of these tools are trained by
example
so simply by annotating examples of the
types of regions or objects you'd like
to
detect the user can very easily create
deep learning apps
without any a priori knowledge of deep
learning or convolutional neural
networks
i'd like to give a couple of examples of
problems where deep learning really
comes into its own
these can be broadly split up into two
types of problems
the first as identified by these middle
two examples
are about detecting areas or regions
within the image
in this case the epidermis of skin or
complex structures in h e such as
necrosis and
tumor and stroma detection
the other broad category of
identification would be object detection
and in this case this is anything that
can be expressed as a discrete object
such as a cell nucleus in either bright
field or fluorescence
glomeruli in a kidney or other cells
stained with
for instance ihc and pdl1 in this case
deep learning can facilitate all of
these workflows in a very robust way
i'd like to move on and talk about some
of the modules that are available in vis
and how they might be used for solving
image analysis problems
the tissue array module is chiefly
designed to de-array
tma slides in this case a tma slide is
simply one that doesn't have a single
piece of tissue or several pieces of
tissue
but can have many tens or hundreds of
individual
cores representing either different
tissues
different patients or different
experimental types
it's a very high density way to collect
data and in this case
what the tissue array module can do is
to break up
each one of these cores into individual
units or images
for processing this way the results of
your analysis
can be intersected across either working
groups tissue types
or different conditions
the tissue array module is a simple
wizard based derang
and has step by step guidance so the
user always knows what they need to do
to advance to the next step if your
scanner has a customized layout file
this can be imported
and apps can be run in line importantly
this can also be combined with our
tissue a line module that i'll talk
about in a little while
for multiplexing in brightfield
just to give you an idea of how easy
this process is
there's a short video here that
introduces the workflow
for tissue array in this case we simply
load in
our core image you can see here it's a
relatively small number
but this is scalable up to even 384 core
layouts a new grid is
designated and the number of cores in x
and y
can be pointed out here the size of each
core is also
estimated in the dialog
once the user is happy with the array
you can then simply
drag the mask over the top of the cores
as shown here
deselect any cores that are not of
interest and then use the fit calls
button
to jog each one of these masks over
the individual course the calls are
de-arrayed
and are available for review at this
point apps can also be run on
all of the calls individually and the
results reported
the next module i'd like to introduce is
that of multiplex phenotyping
this really deals with higher content
data
such as fluorescent multiplex or mass
cytometry imaging
whereby we have more than just a three
channel image
and we can start to collect data that
are up to eight
ten twenty fifty even a hundred
individual channels there's basically no
limits
on the input data that can be used for
the vizio farm platform
and in this case what we offer are
simple tools
to be able to identify phenotype and
cluster individual cells within our
image
the workflow is similar to other ones in
vis whereby
we simply identify cells this can also
be any phenotypic unit of interest
using a deep learning classifier again
this
leverages the robust deep learning tools
that we have
built into our platform once the cells
are detected they can simply be passed
to a secondary app to do the
identification and classification
of our cellular phenotypes
because the vizio farm platform allows
building up
of multiple apps in a single workflow
we can also put apps upstream of our
cell detection here
these apps could do things like outline
tissue sections
detect tumors necrosis or other areas of
interest within the tissue
but also do artifact removal which can
be very helpful for automating workflows
where there are for instance tears or
staining errors
or other objects that we don't want to
count
once our phenotyping classifier has been
run we can produce a range of different
outputs
these are customizable by the user but
just to give you an idea of the sorts of
things that we can create
we can create simple results these could
be things like
counts of a particular phenotype or a
particular cell type
for instance a cd8 positive cell either
as raw counts
or as percentages of a larger population
we can also create heat maps to display
the density of any given class
or any combination of classes very
useful for identifying hot spots
of a particular phenotype
spatial statistics are very important
especially in immuno-oncology
and so we have built-in tools to measure
the object distance
between any two phenotypes for instance
cd8 positive cells and macrophages
we can also calculate the distances
between these phenotypes
and other regions such as invasive
margins
or tumor boundaries
lastly we have a whole suite of
phenographs that are available
as a push button solution this allows
you to display the clustering
information
and to do some exploratory phenotyping
work
all of this with no coding required
i'd like to just highlight whilst on
multiplex phenotyping
two broad approaches to phenotypic
analysis
what we tend to see is that some people
really want to perform
initial exploratory analysis on their
data
this means phenotyping every cell in an
entire tissue
in an unbiased fashion you can see here
the results of phenotyping and hopefully
make out some of the different classes
in different colors once we've
identified this
we can produce a number of different
phenographs to describe the prevalence
the location the clustering behavior and
also the contribution of different
channels
into this phenotyping analysis
another approach if not the exploratory
one is to actually ask
specific questions of your data this
could be something as in this case
like how many or what percentage of the
cells within 20 microns of a melanoma
are cytotoxic t cells to do this we can
use
our built-in vis tools in order to both
identify the melanoma cells
here in magenta and then identify
the individual cells that are proximal
to the melanoma
these are the cyan ones we can then
selectively phenotype
only subsets of this image and then
produce results based
only on those subsets this allows you to
ask these sorts of questions that i just
introduced and in this case the result
is about six percent
of t cells within 20 microns of melanoma
are cytotoxic this wouldn't be possible
without being able to phenotype
our images and our cells and understand
the proportions of all of the different
populations involved in
i'd like to move on and mention tissue
align modules
the tissue align module is very useful
for registering two images together
in this case in the same ethos as our
tissue array module
we have a simple wizard based alignment
here that can provide
step-by-step support through the very
easy process
we've implemented a drag and drop system
to simply take one image
and then drop it onto a second one to
indicate that they're linked
and we can align multiple images even
from different modalities
this could be something as simple as an
h e with an ihc
but also fluorescence to bright field
images
if you have multiple sections on a slide
either together or individually
we can align multiple sections across a
slide
or across separate slides
the automated alignment works very well
but sometimes you may need to drop some
pins and in this case we have a landmark
guided alignment
available
i'd like to mention just a couple of
different applications of our tissue
align module
the first is what i would call the
traditional usage and in this case it's
used to define regions of interest
on the left you can see that we have
both a functional marker
and a tumor marker in serial sections
in this case a pancita keratin gives a
very high contrast
in the tumor regions the ki-67
functional marker
has less obvious boundaries on the tumor
in this case after registration of these
two images
we can define our boundaries of tumor
based on the tumor marker
and then transfer these onto the
functional marker
for subsequent analysis in this case
we're detecting ki-67 positivity
only within the tumor areas
this is an example of aligning serial
sections
but a lot of very interesting work is
being done with
serial staining techniques whereby a
single piece of tissue
is stained and imaged then the stain is
stripped off the tissue
and the tissue is restained with a new
set of markers and probes
this can then be re-imaged and using the
tissue align module
individual images of the same tissue
section can be registered
excitingly because this is the same
tissue these can be registered to a
single cell level
you can see here the result of aligning
four different stains
an h e and three ihc and hopefully you
can make out that there is single cell
alignment here down to a couple of
pixels
this is a really exciting approach
because what it allows for
is cell level phenotyping in bright
field
you can pull in multiple stains from
multiple images
and really start to understand the
complexity of the tissue
without the need for fluorescent markers
the last module i'd like to mention is
brain mapping
in this case we have two different
approaches for brain mapping in the
visio farm platform
the first is using an atlas in this case
what we can do is to take our sections
in this case a coronal of a mouse brain
align a pre-built atlas onto the brain
then we can select the regions of
interest from the brain atlas
this can be any granularity in this case
up to thousands of different regions
within the entire brain stack
these regions can then be converted to
visio farm rois
for further processing or analysis this
is a great approach and very high
precision
but accuracy is highly sample dependent
in this case if parts of the brain are
missing
or altered by disease the atlas may not
align correctly
with the brain regions i'll also mention
that custom atlases can be created
either outside of this or within the
vizio farm platform
the problems with the sample dependence
of atlas mapping
were solved by visiofarm using a deep
learning technique
called context-aware region mapping
in this video you can see another
section of brain
and simply an roi is drawn around the
brain
and then a context aware region mapping
app has been trained against different
regions
within this brain you can see that the
regions are identified
despite the lack of atlas
in this case even if parts of the brain
are missing
damaged or changed the deep learning app
has been trained to recognize these
and because of the context of the brain
or other structured tissue
can then identify these regions
at this point context-aware region
mapping has a lower precision
but is far more robust against tissue
changes
now once we've identified regions of
interest within the brain
we can of course leverage the other
integrated tools in the visio farm
platform
for instance in order to measure these
areas we can define
absolute area measurements or
to perform further analysis using other
apps
in this case we can use for instance
deep learning apps
to identify amyloid plaques in
particular regions of the brain
or of course we can come in and identify
individual cells
count them and classify them in any of
these stains using deep learning
approaches
this really provides a flexibility for
the user
who wants to come in and ask a
particular question using rodent brain
models
so to briefly summarize the vizio farm
platform is a very flexible toolbox
it allows users to solve a wide range of
image analysis problems
not just for today's research but for
tomorrow's analysis too
users can of course build their own apps
using train by example deep learning
that i've demonstrated today
or they can leverage pre-built validated
apps
and you can see the url at the bottom of
the screen here leading to our app
center where there are over 140 examples
of individual apps that have been
validated and tested across a range of
different tissue types
and staining
the capabilities of the core platform
can be extended
with some of these extra modules that
i've shown today things like tissue
align tissue array
the multiplex tools as well as brain
atlas mapping and all are integrated
seamlessly into the platform this means
that these can be combined
with the existing tools that you have
and lastly to reiterate the ethos this
is complex analysis
made simple this makes it easier for
users to learn and use the vizio farm
platform
the last thing i'd like to mention in
this part of the talk is scalability
what i've suggested and shown in demos
so far
are really single solutions
in this case oftentimes once people have
done their due diligence
have qc'd their workflow what they'll
want to do is to scale up processing
and i just wanted to mention how this
looks in the vizio farm platform
we can for instance select a number of
cases this could be
10 100 or a thousand slides that want to
be processed automatically
set up an app workflow simply by
chaining together
multiple apps here i've demonstrated a
tumor detection
and the cell detection and then these
can simply be batch processed
using these tools built into this an
entire study can be selected
and batch processed and this sends them
to the queue for processing
now this is one means of scalability
whereby an app workflow is run
across multiple images but when people
talk about scalability they also want to
talk about
deployment and infrastructure and just
to very quickly mention
that this queue can look the same from
any workstation
but can actually deploy jobs not only to
a single workstation
but to a local cluster or to server
infrastructure
which can be local or can be in the
cloud
and from this way we can scale up to the
processing
and usage requirements of individual
users
for the second part of this talk i'm
delighted to introduce
dr keith bowers a senior business
development manager at oracle bio
he'll be talking about building
customer-centric value for drug
discovery
and development welcome keith the floor
is yours
thank you dave for the introduction
please do allow me one slide to
introduce oracle bio to set the scene
and then i will indeed cover how we
operate as a ceo using visio farm
software
to deliver value to pharma and biotech
clients worldwide
oracle bio is a contract research
organization that specializes
in the quantitative image analysis of
histopathology slides
we generate these data using analysis
workflows that are both robust
and collaborative in nature our
expertise is significant
the company has been established 10
years generating data from complex and
challenging
image analysis scenarios our experience
in this area
is complemented by our personal career
backgrounds
which amounts to decades of experience
within the pharmaceutical industry
not only image analysis but histology
clinical pathology and pharma r d
the purpose of the company our vision if
you like is to drive the adoption and
application
of quantitative digital pathology across
drug
research and development supporting the
progression
of personalized medicine and we operate
our systems
within a quality framework system both
as an overarching
structure to run the company training
logs job descriptions
but also down to details of standard
operating procedures
for individual processes including
algorithm validation
and extending this framework to now be
able to deliver
image analysis projects to a level
expected
for regulatory level reporting the
essence of our delivery to
clients the interrogation of tissue
biology to generate data
to release information held within these
images can be encompassed
in the concept of the quantitative image
analysis workflow
summarize below and in the following
slides
allow me to briefly take you through
these steps
here we start with image management the
transfer of scanned images
we generally receive images using
transfer across
our ignite folder system or through aws
s3 buckets
both highly secure transfer systems
the next step is the all-important
qc and annotation step
the quality of the data from any image
analysis
is underpinned by the quality of these
images
we take great care in ensuring only
image areas that are devoid of
confounding artifacts
whether it be focus scanning lines
tissue folds staining quality
are negatively annotated out of the
process or in cases
the whole image is removed in its
entirety
this essential exercise is burdensome
when performed through manual annotation
we have utilized invisia farm tissue
find algorithms to automatically
identify tissue
and remove white space for example much
reducing the burden of manual
annotations
and then of course we have pathologist
annotations
defining the reasons of interest for
subsequent analysis
and all important experienced eye to
guide the development and training
of the subsequent algorithms for example
we see some obvious artifacts within the
grey annotations
signal for removal and positive
annotations in green to define
regions that we do wish to be analyzed
next up the actual algorithm development
which can be at the tissue level of
course
in this case employing the use of a
vizio farm deep learning algorithm
to distinguish between tumor tissue in
orange
and supporting stroma in blue
but also at the cell level
here we have an example with staining
generated
using one of the serially stained
techniques that dave mentioned earlier
in this case altiview's ultima immuno
oncology 8-plex kit
this cell analysis here we use
visiopharm software capabilities
to define cell shape based upon the cell
lineage biomarker expression
small rounder immune t cells b cells in
the stroma
the larger and more diffuse in shape
macrophages in yellow and of course the
larger tumor cells
bordered in blue and cyan
and finally image processing of the
validated algorithms
and again a level of data checking and
qc
before sending data onto clients
however this brief overview does not
cover the additional requirements of a
workflow
necessary to fully meet the expectations
of our clients
and indeed our own standards the
questions being asked of the biology
are becoming more complex driven by the
appreciation
of the roles of other cellular players
beyond t cells
the search for meaningful biomarkers
cell location proximity
also a known factor these challenges are
being met with advances
in staining technologies advanced in
multiplexing techniques
immunofluorescence and image mass
spectroscopy
but these are putting demands on the
downstream image analysis
not only in terms of the deconvolution
of the biology
but also in terms of actual image size
and the computing power needed to run
the algorithms in a tiny
manner speed and scalability are
paramount
a workflow should not be a black box for
clients
and it must function across multiple
disciplines
pathologists both co and client based
image analysts project biologists it
should operate
in an environment that allows
transparency of decision making
allowing visibility of images and
overlays to confirm the validity
of the data this facilitates the
collaborative ethos
we have found to be essential in order
to deliver meaningful data
of course the data must come in a
reportable fashion generated
in a context of robust reproducible
procedures
that can be trusted validated
authenticated
and i t security to maintain
confidentiality of information
from external threats and ensure data
resilience and durability
the use of visio farm software helps us
meet these demands
the versatility of the viziopharm
software gives us the flexibility
to address the increasing complexity of
pathology images
within the images per se but also the
ensuing
biological questions that are posed the
example i've described earlier
encompasses this multiplex if images
and the ability to label cells based
upon their biomarker defined lineage
we have access to all apps and modules
including visio farm deep learning
plus our use of visio farms subscription
model gives us the ability to offer a
scalable solution
the unlimited licenses and processing of
image number per month allows oracle bio
to process quickly and efficiently image
analysis
projects at oracle bio
we have developed a hybrid it
infrastructure that incorporates both
cloud
and local server capabilities
we deploy the viziopharm software on our
aws
cloud which provides us with unlimited
computing
infrastructure including gpu firepower
needed for aim modules
aws is a vastly scalable on-demand
resource
that allows us to meet client needs in a
cost efficient
manner plus we utilize heavily
video farms batch processing which
allows us to run analysis
over multiple images simultaneously
this allows us to run studies quickly
and return data back to clients in a
timely manner
plus we have a validated version of
visiofarm on our server
stored in a state-of-the-art data center
data vita
to support our regulatory level
reporting needs
both systems have high levels of
security
authentication procedures as does our
use
of the ignite platform and aws s3
buckets for sharing images
at the start of the workflow all images
are encrypted during transfer and
storage
and there are disaster recovery and
backup procedures
in place in both systems to offer peace
of mind
collaboration and visibility of images
is facilitated greatly
by our deployment of a vizio farm viewer
on a web-based portal
this is a proprietary system that we
have called observer
clients can log on to observer where
they have access to their own project
information
it allows images pathology annotations
image analysis do i have cell overlays
to be shared with clients seamlessly
at all points of the workflow process
it thus supports decisions throughout
the workflow
from the concurrence of the initial
pathology annotations
through to an agreement on algorithm
performance criteria
pathologists ever key to this field can
be fully integrated into the workflow
through the use of observer hosted visio
farm
we have two highly trained clinical
pathologists working at oracle bio the
breadth and depth of these individuals
knowledge is remarkable
and again allows oracle bio to respond
quickly to the variety of tissue and
cancer types
that we are exposed to in addition to
this
we have an external network of
pathologists clinical and veterinary
often clients have their own
pathologist's resource that we are happy
to integrate
into our workflow using observer
pathologist annotations are incorporated
into the image analysis workflow
by using the vizio farm tissue align app
for example pathologist annotations from
an h
e image are often co-registered to a
serial ihc biomarker section
to define clearly regions of interest
for subsequent analysis
and finally the workflow and the
associated systems that surround it
are encapsulated in a quality management
framework
confidence in data integrity and quality
is
paramount we established a quality
management framework
on our journey towards offering image
analysis services to a regulatory
standard
we are launching our gcp image analysis
services this quarter
performed using visio farm software
but of course non-regulatory studies
benefit from a quality management
framework
as it represents an adherence to sops
infrastructure and software validation
that pervades
all of oracle bios studies
through the versatility of vizio farm we
offer the image analysis services
across a broad range of staining
technologies
in situ hybridization single geo ihc
tumor microarrays and multiplexing
for example analysis of in-situ
hybridization
using technologies such as rna scope
is a popular approach for the evaluation
of changes in early biomarker expression
or a particular drug response effect in
tissue
in this case single target validation
and target presence
can be supported by us generating data
such as number of pro
positive and negative cells in tissue
rois
per section or classification of pro
positive cells into low medium and high
probe signal content per section single
or dual stain chromogenic ihc
the foundation of tissue histological
investigation is something we
investigate
often here we perform studies to
investigate mechanism of action or
target occupancy for example
reporting data such as the number of
positive cells
intensity and biomarker expression for
cell for example
or quantitating the immune cell
infiltration cell count in tumor border
versus tumor core
we have heard from dave about the
modules for tissue microarray analysis
within the vizio farm tissue array
module
this supports target validation efforts
and patient stratification approaches
across
a broad number of tissue types in an
efficient manner
and here again we report data that
support disease stratification
such as tumor stroma content per core
number of positive cells in specific
rois per core
ihc intensity per cell and h score if
you like
and of course we have multiplex
immunofluorescence which i have alluded
to earlier in this talk
a powerful approach to interrogate
complex tissue
most notably the tumor microenvironment
and here
we report data such as the number of
single dual
triple even quadruple positive cells
within tumor or stroma
we can generate data regarding proximity
analysis
or invasive margin interrogation how
many t
cells have made that transition from the
stroma
into the tumor and these applications
add value across the entire
drug discovery and development pipeline
from target validation studies in early
discovery
pre-clinical through translational and
future clinical
and the use of image analysis within
companion diagnostics
represents a journey that many of us are
on
much of this talk are centered on
processes and infrastructure
but what really makes processes work are
people and relationships
we value our relationship with visiofarm
the communication channels
are open allowing us to work openly to
continue to advance the impact
that image analysis and digital
pathology has
and will continue to have on basic
science and patient care
i would like to thank them for the
opportunity they gave me to speak
on behalf of oracle bio thank you
great thank you for the excellent
presentation well it's interesting to
see how all this technology is really
absorbing these pathology workflows
we'd like to thank david and keith and
oracle bio for their time
and thank you for watching if you have
any questions please feel free to
contact us
at webinar visiofarm.com or check out
our other webinars or additional content
available in the knowledge library on
the vizio farm website
thanks and have a great day